an engineer in our society they they
don't look like me but I'm here to break
that mold
[Music]
my name is deja Moe Williams and it's
kind of hard to explain but I don't
worry deja deja is a manufacturing
engineer at NASA's Jet Propulsion lab
and she's also a musician Wilson I
literally couldn't have said it better
myself
Thank You deja let's get back to where
it all started JJ's love of science all
began when she was growing up in st.
Louis I grew up on the south side of st.
Louis Missouri in a single-parent
household with my mom I got into science
because of a program that my mom kicked
down doors to give me into they exposed
us to different science topics such as
robotics chemistry you name it in
college they just studied engineering
management while there she faced more
than just challenging schoolwork a lot
of times in class I was the only female
I was the only black female sometimes
people didn't want to sit by you
sometimes people didn't want to help you
you know I will see a lot of times that
people will have their how I'm trying
not to cry people have their little
groups that they will study within I
would have to like infiltrate like how
can I bond with that group so that I can
get the same resources that my people
don't have when I figured it out of
course she figured it out which brings
us to NASA deja is part of a team
building rocket ships they take an
engineer's idea and figure out how to
make it a reality which is pretty
freakin cool now remember a minute ago
when we mentioned that deja was also a
musician she wrote a song about science
to the tune of soldier boys crank that
I'm just right now like yo this is hot X
equals in this old negative be lesser
motor square root of b squared minus 4ac
first I'm not fine
but hey rude over to a root over - hey
Dasia realized that through music you
can open up a whole new audiences eyes
to the world of science something she
wished she had when she was young but
it's not just writing a song and that's
it like I actually take it a step
further and am a mentor to a lot of
students who either interested in
science or already in college and just
need that extra push to continue and
finish I want to show through my life
that you can be an engineer you can't be
a musician
yo the sky's the limit
[Music]
you